can you tell us the reasons why being a
screenwriter is impossible
yeah absolutely that actually
the in many ways i would advise no one
to be a screenwriter it is by far one of
the dumbest
arts to try and be in other than maybe a
large-scale architecture
the first thing about screenwriting is
you're never getting to finish
the work in other words you get to
finish the script but it's not
available to an audience until it's made
by other people
so basically you're creating something
in order to give to a bunch of other
people so they'll create
another thing and frankly a different
thing the thing that's based in your
script is a production
and it will change in many ways um
so if you really are like i can totally
picture this movie in my head and that's
why i'm writing it
get over it it will never ever be like
that even in the greatest of
circumstances where things are better
than you want
it will never be as you imagine but
honestly i believe that's the creative
process itself
when you imagine a script it actually
comes out
differently than you first imagined it
or what you think
the process of transforming anything
into a concrete work
out of an abstract thought changes it
and honestly when a reader reads it it's
going to change again because when you
say
he wore a red tie they're going to
picture a different red tie that you're
picturing
and you have to be able to accept that
you have to be able to accept that the
script is a
a piece of a project that you will not
have any control over
so that's number one is unless you
really like that process
of doing something for other people to
work from it's frustrating
and i know actually a lot of writers get
very irritated actors and directors
which is too bad
because they should be more respectful
of the other arts
but they're like they didn't say that
like i thought they should like i know
how that line should go
and that's not how it works the line
goes how it goes in their mouth
the actor has to be free to act the way
they would act it
and if you are depending on them saying
it exactly the way you imagined it
which is frankly not on the page it's
not going to happen
so writing screenwriting is more
frustrating than most types of writing
but then not only that among most types
of writing you have less control
because you don't own the copyright to
your work
if you're a novelist or a playwright or
any other kind of writer
you own your work they can't somebody
may put
pressure on you we you know we won't
publish it unless you change it but they
actually can't change it
if you write a script and you sell it to
a company for various reasons having to
do with the ability to unionize back in
the 30s
screenwriters gave up their right to own
their
creative work which means when you hire
on to write something
they can fire you and have someone else
rewrite it and you cannot do anything
about it
and that always sounds like oh that'll
be fine i'll live with that it
hurts everyone gets fired everyone gets
rewritten
most of my career was rewriting other
people and i had to be aware of the fact
that
somebody out there is grinding their
teeth and cursing my name when
if i do well so
screenwriting is just a tough business
then you get to the fact that for most
writers now you're going to be working
on a staff
of a show which means it's not even your
idea
you are one of a bunch of people
contributing ideas and
the actual writer of the show the
creator the showrunner
is going to be saying yes to that no to
that
that line is good that line is good
we'll put them together
you may get creative satisfaction you
may be doing
grunt work you may also i mean on a
feature i wrote
there was an introductory scene of a
character um
that i just hated the way the producers
wanted
this character to be introduced they
they thought she was cute
and i thought she was reprintable and i
kept saying do you
really want her to say that and they're
like yeah we think it's funny and i was
like
i didn't have an hr i had to write the
scene the way they asked for it or i
would be fired or someone else would be
hired to replace or rewrite that scene
that's not what most people picture as
being an artist it's not what most
people picture as being a writer
but i can go on the number of reasons
that you shouldn't be a screenwriter are
enormous
the reasons that most people want to be
screenwriters are misleading first of
all they think
and it's true you are very very highly
paid if you
are a working screenwriter um in
the unions in the studio system the
network system
um that is a very small percentage of
the people who
are trying to be writers so
it's like saying i want to be a baseball
player and you're imagining i'm going to
be
major league
most people are not going to be major
league the question is would you stop
playing baseball then and i i can't
imagine i can't imagine saying i want to
be an artist
but only if they'll pay me first that's
that's not how generally arts should
work
um
most people imagine that screenwriters
have a uh
get to people come to the writer because
honestly
and this is a problem of the
screenwriting industry um you know the
everyone who teaches you know they're
all saying like it all begins with the
script the script is so important
and you get all these actors and
directors are saying like you know and
it's true
they choose a good script to work on
it's like we couldn't do this without
the script
and wannabe screenwriters are like i'm
so important
and i promise you you're not they are
going to change your work
they are going to misinterpret your work
that's just part
of the job you are providing a beginning
to someone else's creative process
and so that's a hard
thing to almost every screenwriter i
know
is looking for a creative outlet they're
looking for
they're writing novels on the side or
plays or they're painting or
whatever and you wouldn't think that
that's what
being a successful screenwriter is but
truthfully
it is it's a it's a job it's a glorious
job and when it works right you have
these amazing experiences
where talented people take your work and
they like your arc
and they do stuff and it works and then
it goes out to a big audience
and that's a little tiny slice of the
experience
the things i've had made were amazing
they're only two
three percent of what i actually worked
on most of what i worked on no one will
ever hear of
it's trapped in some company's vault
somewhere or
in my drawer because no one bought it
and i'm talented i'm
good i'm successful i'm in the union i'm
highly paid
and most of what i write is rejected
so yeah be a painter if you can
because at least you get done you have
the finished painting
but the flip side of that so that i
don't just discourage the heck out of
everybody
the flip side is if you get good at it
you learn certain skills about narrative
and character
that are invaluable no matter what
else you try to do creatively if you
want to be a director
it's great to know what screenwriting
really is what a
scene and a character really are
it's very important to understand how
much the character's
motivation the character's goal their
the thing they're trying to do
that's crucial and if you're writing a
novel it's just as important
and if you're writing a graphic novel or
a video game
whatever it is those basic ideas about a
character
wanting something and having a difficult
time getting it
that is the center of any kind of
narrative
creativity and screenwriting pushes that
harder than most
if you can learn it in screenwriting you
can do it anywhere so
it's sort of good to learn to be a
screenwriter because then you've got a
skill set
if you decide to work in video games
great you're going to be
really really set and when you were
temping
in new york city were you attempting to
be an author or
it was when you wrote that play and then
you saw it was sort of
goldman-esque and you thought let's do
screen no
ever since i was like a kid i when i see
something i want to
do it like paint i was painting for a
while i was drawing i was
i was writing plays i was trying
to direct movies i was trying to write
movies on super 8 silent
film which is means i had to actually
learn how to make silent movies so
i like to say i came up in silent film
it was in the 1970s but
that was all they had then if you were
going to make if you're a high school
student you want to make a movie
they had eight millimeter home movie
cameras i would make silent movies
um i tried to write novels because i
love novels
uh plays because i love plays i have a
dangerous
desire to do absolutely anything i see
so no i was i was always doing all of it
and i would sort of shift my focus
depending on what was practical
when i was in high school i got tired of
silent movies it was frustrating to not
have any dialogue
but high school they had plays so i
started to write plays
um high school and college i did plays i
got out of college
i was sort of thinking of writing plays
sort of thinking of writing novels
but screenwriting i thought that would
pay
for all of them if i could get
screenwriting jobs i could afford to do
everything else
and then for 12 years i was in office
temp and couldn't afford to do anything
except
right in my off time um but the theory
always was
i was going to do it all and
screenwriting was just the most
lucrative which is what everybody thinks
and
and you know yeah for the major leagues
it's very lucrative
for the rest of us it's not and you
should really
want to do it you should love doing it
even if no one pays you
you